What is the issues so I can help you?
I don't know what your problem is
because you said it once ago and you
forgot but you came here you want
clarification.
I don't know what troubled you because I
wasn't the one troubled when
you're at it because I don't know. So
you got to help me. Help me to help you.
What is it? Okay.
So it says
uh uh
These profess to hold the faith of
Abraham and together with us they adore
the one merciful God.
>> profess that. Do they profess the God of
Abraham?
They claim it but it it's
>> profess it, right?
Yeah, but it's demonstrably false.
How do you know it's demonstrably false?
Because Muhammad is a false prophet.
What does that got to do with the nature
of God? So you're saying they're wrong
not about God
>> So a false prophet can't
talk about the Trinity?
Let's say a false prophet came said God
is triune.
Because there were false prophets in
Israel who did acknowledge Jehovah as
God.
So they're wrong?
No.
Okay. So what do you mean in a sense?
So it does not follow false prophet ipso
facto you're announcing a false God. You
can be a false prophet and still speak
of the true God but you're a false
prophet for other reasons. For example,
preaching a false gospel.
Yeah.
Uh uh So how do you know that it's a
false God? And I'm not disagreeing with
you. I want to see how much you know and
why you come to that conclusion.
Well, they claim Ishmael and there
there's no evidence for that, right?
What does that got to do with the nature
of God? So you're saying they're wrong
not about God but about Ishmael in the
covenant. That's not the same.
Well, that that's a starting place and
then uh the the doctrine's just
completely
anathema. Like it it's
You keep speaking generalities. I'm
asking for specifics. Like what?
In Islam?
Brother, you just made an assertion. Are
you listening to yourself?
I guess not.
How long do you think you're going to
last, brother?
I was hoping a little bit, but you know,
if you got to send me on my way, that's
fine.
>> You just told me
the doctrines are wrong. I said, "Like
what?"
"In Islam?" Then, "No, Christianity has
wrong doctrines."
You said in the
>> Okay.
You just said their doctrines are wrong.
I go, "Like what? In Islam?"
"No, in Hinduism." What are we talking
about, brother?
Well, I mean, it calls for the murder of
unbelievers and
everything like
calls for the murder of unbelievers and
So, you mean in the Old Testament when
God says apostates are to be killed,
that's murder?
Notice he you again went to legal and
moral issues, not the nature of God.
What does that got to do with
Muslims
professing
the God of Abraham? You're having a
problem with their legal system, their
ethical system. How does that touch upon
that they're acknowledging
the God of Abraham? And if we follow
your criteria in the Old Testament,
apostates are to be killed.
So,
what is your argument
that when paragraph 841 says that
Muslims profess the God of Abraham,
which they do,
"And together with us adore the one
God." Meaning,
they are adoring the one God of Abraham
like we adore.
In other words, it's simply a statement
of fact in that when you ask them, "Who
is the one God you adore?" "The God of
Abraham." Well, that's the God we adore.
You haven't give me an example to show
me why that's wrong.
I guess I don't know it well enough, but
I have an understanding that it can't
be.
>> why would you have a problem with the
paragraph
when you don't know
what Islam teaches about God
for you to be troubled with that
statement?
You just said, "I don't know about the
Quran, but
but what?"
Well, it just seems like we're
conflating the two and it it appears
that
What's the proof that's a conflation?
Give me some proof.
The the
the spirit that came to Muhammad and was
pressing him to read.
Brother, do you know
your Old Testament, which you don't
know, Numbers 22 to 24, a false prophet
named Balaam
who worshipped false gods prophesied
uttered prophecies from the true God by
the true spirit and his prophecies are
written in your Old Testament.
What are you not getting? Even a false
prophet
can speak of the true God though he's
deceived
by an evil spirit
to proclaim the true God, but then get
everything else wrong to then get you to
follow
something that is wrong other than the
God that he's pronouncing.
What do you not get?
So, I think I'm understanding like it it
is literally just that they're mistaken
and led astray.
Literally what?
Mistaken and led astray.
Yes, they're mistaken and led astray
into thinking they have the God of
Abraham.
Okay.
But why would we then as Christians
affirm what they have with the the
catechism?
So, how do you want me to
meet them in order to bring them the
fullness of the truth by saying, "You
worship Baal, who is Satan, and you're
going to hell?"
So, why didn't Paul adopt your attitude
when at the Areopagus, Mars Hill, with
the Athenians, Epicureans, and Stoics,
Okay. who had idols, which were demons
that they worshipped.
He then pointed to the altar of the
unknown God and said, "That's the God I
proclaim to you."
Why did he do that? He should have
followed your logic.
And if you have that
>> Okay. paragraph 841, they even quote
Acts 17 as a basis to make that
statement and argue the way they do.
It doesn't.
Oh, who?
Uh I don't
I don't see it here, but it might
Paragraph 841, if I bring it up and I
show you they reference Acts 17.
Plan of salvation, also
It says
All right, man.
Yeah, maybe I'm just reading it from a
bad source, though.
No, it's not a bad source. They'll have
notes, notes at the bottom,
where they footnote what they're
quoting.
Is that LG 16?
It's a lot of notes, brother. If I bring
it up here, man, I'm going to read it
out.
I fell on Okay. Okay.
Sorry, sir.
I don't I don't mean to do this to you.
Sorry, brother. You're doing You were
sent here to purge me so I can be more
holy and sanctified.
All right.
Lumen gentium, here.
Gentium over there.
And then this one here.
You see when it says number 325, 326,
327? See these numbers?
Yeah. This one only tells me 330. Did
you open up the entire section where
this is found? Because it's those who
have not yet received the gospel are
related to people of God in various
ways.
So, the context is those who don't know
the gospel, right?
Okay, yes.
And it begins with the Jewish people
who had the Old Testament
but arguing of the gospel.
Right?
And then it goes to the Muslims.
The church relationship with Muslims,
the plan of salvation also includes
those who acknowledge the creator.
The first place amongst the amongst them
are the Muslims.
So, does God plan to save them or no?
I'm sure he will do as he wishes. No,
does he have Muslims in mind
when Christ died to save the world? Does
Christ death include
the salvation
for Muslims or he he puts them aside?
No, Christ won't die for you.
No, it's all people.
Okay.
So, the context if you had read it,
the Catholic Church recognizes 843 in
other religions that search among
shadows and images for the God who's
unknown, yet near, since he gives life
and breath and all things and wants all
men to be saved. This is the part that's
from Acts 17.
Okay.
Acts 17
25.
This is life and breath and all things.
That's Acts 17:25.
Which I don't know why I didn't
cross-reference it here. Thus, the
church considers all goodness and truth
found in these as a preparation for the
gospel
and given by him who enlightens all men
that they may at least have life. Why
don't you read the context that tells
you
that we go with the light they have to
bring them to the gospel of Christ?
I guess I was so shocked by the the
first paragraph that
I disregarded the rest of it. And then
you said you read my article, too.
That's what's killing me, dude.
I I think I read just what you had wrote
and maybe some of this in the the bold.
So, if God has
revealed himself
in creation
as well as in the conscience of the
heart.
And we know God is true and cannot lie.
Then what should your duty be?
To look for that revelation in these
cultures and traditions that you know is
from God to use that as a bridge, right?
Yeah.
So,
since Islam comes after Christianity
and interacts with Christianity,
you'll find in the Quran a lot of
commonality and truths.
Truths because they agree with the
Bible. Anything that agrees with the
Bible is true.
So, what should I do?
Focus on
the similarities
and bring them to the fullness of the
truth or focus on the fact that the
origin of Islam, all of Islam, was
originally Baal,
the moon god, and that's Satan,
or bypass that and go with the things
that
are found in the scripture,
which are true, and use that to bring
them to the fullness of the truth. In
other words,
the Jews say in their Talmud, Mary's a
The Quran says Mary's the
greatest creature God created.
The Jews say in their Talmud, Jesus is
The Quran says Jesus is the Messiah,
the word of God sent to Mary,
a spirit from God, born of a virgin,
no man had sex with her.
She remained a virgin. He's a miracle
worker.
Gave sight to the blind, raised the
dead, created from clay a bird, blew
into it, and the bird came to life. Is
taken physically to heaven and will
return physically.
Now,
should I then
focus on all those things the Quran gets
right, confirmed by the Bible, to then
bring them
to the fullness of the truth, or should
I ignore those things
that are in agreement with the Bible and
focus on disagreements.
We we Yeah, we should
focus on what is similar. No, you just
condemned the Catechism for doing that
very thing.
Yeah, well, you know,
this is why I asked cuz I I felt like
>> condemned them for saying what they are
saying.
You just condemned them for saying,
"Look, the Muslims profess the God of
Abraham and together with us they adore
the one God."
They focus on what they profess to show
they're in agreement with us and you
just condemned them to hell.
So, damn if the Catechism does, damn if
it doesn't. Make up your mind, friend.
Okay, okay. I I see.
Uh
You know, it's been troubling me for a
minute, so I appreciate you going into
that.
All right. Now, here you're going to
read for me,
right?
>> Okay.
Let me go to Legacy Standard Bible. So,
damn if you do, damn if you don't. Is
that your policy, mister?
No.
Well, you sure damned the Cat- Catechism
for doing what Paul did, for doing what
the Bible says,
in order to use that light to bring them
to the fullness of the light of Jesus
Christ.
Forgive me for my ignorance, sir. No,
no, I don't need to forgive you. I'm not
God, man. You're not sinning against me.
Who the hell am I?
Fair enough. Who the hell am I? You
ain't sinning against me.
Fair enough. I'll I'll ask God for
forgiveness. All right.
Now,
let's see what Paul did. Did he do what
the Catechism did or should say the
Catechism does to follow the footsteps
of Paul?
Read from 16 cuz I want to save my
voice.
Okay. Now, while Paul was waiting for
them at Athens,
his spirit was being provoked within him
as he was observing the city full of
idols.
So, he was reasoning in the synagogue
with the Jews
and the God-fearing Gentiles, and in the
marketplace every day with those who
happened to be present.
And also some of the Epicureans and
Stoic philosophers were conversing with
them.
Some were saying, "What would this
idle babbler wish to say?"
Others, "He seems to be a proclaimer of
strange deities."
Because he was proclaiming the good news
of Jesus and the resurrection. And they
took him and brought him to the
uh
Areopagus
saying
Areopagus saying,
"May we know what this new teaching is
which you are speaking?
For you are bringing some strange things
to our ears, so we want to know what
these things mean."
Now, all the Athenians and the strangers
visiting there
used to spend their time in nothing
other than telling or hearing something
new.
But Paul stood in the midst of the
Areopagus and said, "Men of Athens, I
observe that you are very religious in
all all respects.
For while I was passing through and
examining the objects of your worship, I
also found an altar with this
inscription, 'To an unknown God.'
Therefore,
what you worship in ignorance, this I
proclaim to you." Now, pause right
there, buddy. He said they're very
religious.
Mhm.
How come he didn't come out and write
that outright condemn them for their
idolatry?
Because then they wouldn't listen at
all.
Oh, so you mean the catechism is
following Paul more than you?
Of course. Of course.
And then this unknown God, he says they
do worship God, but they worship him in
ignorance cuz they don't know much about
him.
Okay.
So when a Muslim tells me he worships
the God of Abraham,
I want to say, "No, you don't. You
worship Satan."
Who's being more like Paul and following
the example of Paul, the catechism or
you?
The catechism.
All right. Now, look what he does with
this unknown God. Look, he says, "You
are worshipping my God,
but you are worshipping in ignorance cuz
you don't know much about him."
Yeah.
>> So should I begin with Muslims with that
approach?
The God of Abraham you worship, that's
the God I worship. But let me tell you
about him. He's triune.
Right?
Yeah.
All right. But you didn't follow Paul.
You followed your understanding because
you misread the
the paragraph. Didn't bother to read in
context. Didn't bother to read my
article in context or watch the
sessions. So then look what he says.
Reread 23 again and keep reading.
Reread 23?
For while I was passing through and
examining the objects of your worship, I
also found an altar with this
inscription, "To an unknown God."
"Therefore, what you worship in
ignorance, this I proclaim to you.
The God who made the world and all
things in it, since he is Lord of heaven
and earth,
does not dwell in temples made with
hands,
nor is he
served by human human hands,
Yeah.
>> as though he needed anything,
since he himself gives to all people
life and breath and all things.
And he made for one man every nation
of mankind to
the catechism quoted where it says he
gives to above all people life and
breath and all things.
Yeah.
What was the catechism quoting?
Paul.
Acts 17:25.
Yep, Paul.
And you sat in judgment of them, huh?
Not realizing you sat in judgment of
Paul.
But read 26 all the way to 28.
And he made from one man every nation of
mankind
to inhabit all the face of the earth
having determined their appointed times
and the boundaries of their habitation
that they would seek God if perhaps they
might grope for him and find him.
Though he is not far from each of us,
each one of us.
For in him we live and move and exist as
even some of your own poets have said,
for we also are his offspring. Now, you
got a problem, buddy.
He's talking to Greeks,
philosophers, Stoics, Epicureans, and
idolaters who worship false gods, right?
Right. Why is he quoting one of their
poets
who would be a Greek pagan philosopher?
Because it's it relates in a way.
But hold on, when the catechism appeals
to what Muslims believe in their Quran,
you're saying you're troubled at heart.
So, that's why I say find you a new
religion cuz Paul did the very thing.
Yeah.
That's why I told you earlier go find
you a new religion, brother.
Oh, I can't do that, Sam. Because Paul
did the same thing.
Yeah. And to make it worse for you,
these two quotes, we know their source.
That tells you Paul was very literate.
He had studied the pagan sources.
Both statements,
one is from Epimenides and the other is
Aratus,
and they're talking about Zeus as the
father of the the gods and the father of
humanity.
The quotes are about Zeus, and he took
those quotes about Zeus,
a false god, and applied it to the true
god.
Yeah.
Why would he quote two sources,
Epimenides, and I'll show you the
source that confirms it, and Aratus,
where they talked about Zeus being the
father of humanity?
That Zeus is mankind's father. We are
the offspring of Zeus,
and we exist in Zeus,
and he took that and applied it to his
god, the unknown god.
So, the catechism is more biblical, more
like Paul than you are and those who
attack the catechism, like Jay Dyer.
Yeah. I I see that.
>> than that clown and those clowns that
follow him, cuz that tells you they've
read their Bible and gathered these
insights from Paul. That if Paul did it,
that means he's telling us we can do it.
Yeah.
And to show you that he's quoting
pagan poets. And by the way, what did
you show them? You know this unknown
god? That's the god I worship. That's
the god who sent me. This unknown god is
telling you he doesn't need your idols
and your images.
So, if you are fearful of this god, and
you want to honor this god, well, I'm
here to tell you that god, that you know
exists, but you don't know much about
him, doesn't want you to worship him
through idols.
See what he did?
Yeah. Let me show you where he's quoting
from. The sources will tell you.
In fact, any good Bible commentary will
even give you the exact quotations from
the pagan poets because
their writings have survived in copies.
So, let's see.
Let's go here.
New American Bible revised edition will
tell you where he's quoting from.
New American Bible revised edition.
We'll go right here.
And then we're going to go here.
Footnotes. Hey, what is Paul quoting
from?
Oh, gee, he's quoting two pagans talking
about Zeus. Oh, really? Yeah.
Read the footnote here.
In him we live live and move
and have our being. Some scholars
understand this saying to be based on an
earlier saying of Epimenides of Knossos.
>> Epimenides of Knossos. 600
>> too
500 years before the birth of our Lord
Jesus Christ.
Okay. For we too are his offspring.
Here Paul is quoting Aratus of Soli,
a 3rd century BC poet from Sicilia.
Cilicia. Now,
they're talking about Zeus and they're
Greek pagans.
That tells you guys, listen,
Paul studied Greek literature, Greek
philosophy.
He knew their sources.
He studied them.
That means here you have a biblical
basis to study the sources of the people
you're witnessing,
to find truth in them, to use them to
your advantage. That's why I use the
Quran to prove the truth of the Bible.
But he's taking statements about Zeus
and he's Christianizing them, saying
these statements are about the God that
you are aware exists, but you don't know
much about him. They're not about Zeus.
If he can do that about Zeus, who's a
pagan god,
why do you have a problem
using the Quran, which says that Allah
is the god of Abraham, not a pagan god
who's married to a pagan goddess, who
has orgies? No, it says Allah is the god
of Abraham.
Says that.
How much more can we use the Quran that
at least claims Allah is the god of
Abraham? If he's going to quote
pagans talking about Zeus whom no Greek
thought was the god of the Old
Testament.
The god of Abraham.
Right. There's there's more there to
relate to. Ah.
You got it, my friend. Let me show you
now
what the new English translation says
the quotes are coming from.
And then you see, so you sat in judgment
you didn't know much about
the context. You didn't even read the
context to see what they're saying.
And you based it on even
abysmal ignorance of the Quran.
And you sat in judgment on a document
produced by brilliant minds of the
Catholic Church, theological
philosophers who spent a lifetime
studying ancient sources, the Bible in
original languages.
And they're guilty until proven innocent
as opposed to assuming I'll give them
the benefit of the doubt.
Yeah, that that was my ignorance.
No, brother, it was mine. But anyway,
Acts 17:28
>> It was not used at all.
What's the footnote say in Acts 17:28?
This quotation is from Aratus
Phaenomena. Right?
Phaenomena.
Even gives you the book.
Okay. Paul
asserted a general relationship and
accountability to God for all humanity.
So,
where's the problem now, man?
I guess that clears it up.
The problem was was Yeah, the the
problem was with me.
Yep.
So, it's not
>> lack of understanding.
It's not that all of the Quran is the
true God.
No.
It's that the Quran claims that Allah is
the true God, and Muslims think it's the
true God. So, you take what they believe
and bring them to the fullness of the
truth.
Yeah.
Once they realize the true character of
God, they're going to know that Islam is
a satanic deception.